confrontation between Pro and to eat
Trump's supporters has reached a new
level
after a Michigan University student was
labeled a white supremacist
despite being Asian on fliers that were
spread across her university campus
Cathy Shu was depicted wearing a manga
make America great again cap she was
also shown making an OK gesture
apparently which was or has been in the
past adopted by some white supremacist
groups earlier this year she was
stripped of a beauty queen title for
offensive and inappropriate tweets in
her to now deleted post Kathy blamed
black people themselves for the majority
of deaths in their community and mocked
a triage up on booth here's what she
told us about the event right now I
think that people automatically assume
that they know about you and what you
stand for because of your political
affiliation I think that we have to open
a dialogue in conversation in order for
all of us to understand each other
better because I have a following on
Twitter I think people found out about
that at my school and they saw that I
was trauma supporter and automatically
assumed that I was associated with like
white supremacy and stuff there were
just Flyers around my school they're
posting about it saying that I was a
white supremacist my friends I mean
these Flyers these pictures saying that
you know they're all posted all over the
school I don't know exactly who did it
but right now I'm in contact with the
police
people are just less taller right now
it's not really a good thing right now
but we're just her trying to figure out
how to solve these issues by promoting
free speech and such since Internet is
such a big thing we should somewhat
figure out if things are considered
libel or slander at this point because
if you do say dangerous things about
someone they should definitely which
they would definitely get hurt in
society the violence against Trump
supporters definitely nights of movement
as a whole because we know how absurd at
what Southwood is happening right now
being you know attacked and stuff just
for having a political affiliation
you